[Music]
as many of you probably know we do not
tape a show on Friday but we still come
into the office and work a full day okay
everyone's supposed to arrive by 9:30
a.m. including myself people on the
staff started telling me that one of our
producers Jordan shlonsky there he is
yeah that's really him at one of our
producers Jordan slansky
doesn't come into the office on Fridays
until early afternoon and then he's been
consistently doing this for a long time
well since I'm the boss last Friday I
decided to look into this claim that
Jordan comes in late on Fridays I had a
camera crew with me I think it was a
very good use of my time
here's what happened I'm sitting in the
office of Jordan shlonsky he's an
associate producer at the show and it's
come to my attention recently that on
Fridays
for some reason he doesn't come in till
very late it is now 12 29 slansky
so I'm sitting and I'm waiting for him
because I want to get to the bottom of
what the Jordans on a Friday he's got a
kaiser roll in a bag
olive oil his own mini specialized
pepper grinder this it's got a giant
thing of Clorox wipes now does this look
like the office of someone who's afraid
of my dreams
allô fresh hydrating gel espresso cups
he's got to Casey ever makes a friend
[Laughter]
step the death squad commander in its
box
and a backup why would you have to he
was supposed to go to with Children's
Hospital and he's hiding them in his
office
I'm curious oh of course
cufflinks his wedding day
[Applause]
and there but he's back I'm sure these
are insured by Lloyds of London if
anyone ever wants to get Jordan a
wedding present I believe he's
registered at Toys R Us
[Music]
that's your reaction you just walk into
your office feels like an acceptable
reaction to me Jordan do you know what
time it is 12:30 actually it's 12:15
it's come to my attention that you like
to drift in late on Fridays okay well I
work later on Fridays than a lot of
people and I feel like I'm able to
adequately accomplish what I need to in
the time that I'm here I've prepared my
daily tasks ahead of me already your
daily tasks what's your daily tasks pour
olive oil into it guys are all I ask you
Jordan what you were doing this morning
well I woke up I immediately had a
protein shake I've been experimenting
with oats and waiting with oats in way I
was trying to avoid synthetic melted
dextran which is derived from corn and I
had read that oats is a good source of
complex carbohydrates in the mix this
way can I ask you a quick question are
you wearing your sunglasses while you're
making the shake you're working to
remove them what do you think would be
the human thing well you've studied
humans on our plan yeah wild move then
it makes you more comfortable
okay you got up you had your way and oh
shape then what then I prepared my body
in various ways
saved it and what do you mean okay I
want to make it very clear to everyone
at home this has come really happening
this is completely real
this isn't scripted you just said all
those things this is a real person who
said that people asking me how did you
find that guy who writes his stuff you
just said that you just said I prepare
my body in various ways did you say you
shaved it a digit remove your shirt
please
you don't mind so this is freshly shaved
this area no I didn't say I shaved my
chest I didn't say like a plant are you
Bobby
what part of your body did you shave my
face oh just your face I'm say it down
below down south I believe that's a
private matter you just took your shirt
off your ass I just asked you if you
shave you appear you're John Dory do you
matter you draw the line there in terms
of talking about my daily grooming which
was yes yes okay you can put your shirt
back on
wait a minute the sunglasses on believe
the shirt off can I ask you why you have
this instead of just a regular packet of
pepper that's a pepper mill yeah
I've never seen anything like this
before why is it so small it allows me
to use fresh pepper on the food that I
eat without taking up and in order to
amount of all deaths based right you
wouldn't want to clutter his face why do
you have these they were sent to me by
whom by a woman that I know a woman sent
you these correct a very definition of
having this is proof that you don't know
a woman
you're not making eye contact with me
what is your intention to hang on to
these or to give them to a worthy
children's charity undecided I'd like to
help you be on time from now on I think
that that would be good for you so we
have some devices that might help would
this be helpful to you this clock I
don't see how you could have this at
home and it would tell you what time it
is and then you would know I should
probably get to work my lack of
awareness at the time is not responsible
for the hour that I arrive in the office
I'd like you to hang this one in the
office and I'd like you to strap this
one to your Vespa it'll be sort of the
Italian douchebag flava flav I also want
you to know that you're being monitored
at all times by this camera I will
constantly be monitoring that camera to
make sure that one of my workers is a
real busy bee buzz buzz this is a good
old-fashioned time card
you are to punch in and punch out every
day I've had this machine brought back
would you like to check in yeah I think
the device works try again you have to
put it in the very center you know how I
knew it was the very center you know
I've worked for a living
he's a real human being